well this is such an honor i have to
tell you this is my first face-to-face
interview in like a year and a half so
to do with an icon like yourself just
feels incredibly special how does it
feel for you to be back and celebrating
art at a place like tiff where you have
been many years i've been here many
years but it is also my first live
interview
in 18 months so i'm so grateful to be
here see your shining face and i
couldn't be happier to be here in
toronto for the film festival which i
love and respect and have been here so
many times with
all sort of all my favorite movies
um
and uh i've worked in canada so much
um so to you know to be able to come
here in person and see it in a film in a
theater tonight with actual real human
beings i'm like
heaven it's not happening yeah it is
heaven this film the good house is
incredible your performance in this
blew me away i think this film really
speaks to a lot of people
a lot of people
have people in their lives who struggle
with addiction and mental health and
those types of things when you were
first approached with this what was it
that drew you to this character
well hildy's just great company
you know she's just like a dane
and she's sort of like a good time girl
kind of friend you'd like to go out
you know and have a few drinks with at
the local bar
and what i what you know as a
an actor of my age
to to get a role where
i can
speak directly to the audience and say
you know like
look at the
look at what the state my life is in now
just you know
i thought it was so liberating for me
and also she's so funny and i do love
comedy more than anything
and i had a great cast i had kevin klein
and rob delaney and marina bakaran and i
mean it was just
we had a wonderful
canadian cast canadian crew
you know it was just a heaven job
you and kevin have quite a history
together like what is that relationship
like you've worked together
over the last few decades is it to like
kind of like a brother-sister friendship
at this point now or is it do you bounce
off of each other a lot i would say we
went to buying drama schools so there is
still that
sort of
my training's better than yours kind of
thing so we have that little competitive
spark
but other than that it is very much
um
[Music]
he teases me to death which always makes
me laugh because he's so funny um
but there's great affection there and i
think great trust
and i was thrilled he did this we've
never seen kevin kline like this before
frank the garbage man and so in a way
it's our favorite romance together
because we're actually
you know we
we do care about each other and
we're meant to be together and
it just has its ups and downs you know
but it was great fun great fun to be
there
yeah that chemistry between you two and
this is great uh what i love about the
film is breaking that fourth wall when i
was sitting down and watching it i just
didn't expect it because it's not
something you typically see in a film
and as a actor you're trained like do
not look dead into the camera you know
so for you to wrap your brain around
that what was that like for you was it a
bit of a weird experience to just kind
of look directly down that lens well you
know
it's funny because in in traditional
theater and shakespeare or whatever
you're always talking to the audience
you're always like listen you know the
truth is that it's like this and the
audience is always on your side when you
do those asides
um they're always in that dilemma with
you and so it felt completely natural to
me
who does hildy have to talk to except
her dogs
and a bottle nobody
so for me to be able to look at look
into the camera and go
thank god you're there can you believe
this you know it's just is this too much
can i please have a drink at the end of
the day
you know and i i so rooted for hildy to
have that drink
you know
gosh she supports everyone in her family
and
all this you know she's clawed her way
up to where she is now
and um
he's trying so hard not to drink
you know she just deserves a break at
the end of the day
um so it was great to be able to look at
the camera and just
in her own very
you know
dark funny way just say
are you watching this do you hear what
i'm hearing you know yeah
i love tilde like very flawed of course
but also a heart of gold like she's
really trying to help her children help
everyone around her do you see a bit of
your own self in that character in that
way
i'd love to be more like hildy
sometimes i'm so serious when i try to
help people
but i guess she is too no i guess there
was so much for me to relate to in
in hilde um
i have a lot of my family members are
actual mormons
so
if i go to a wedding there's often
nothing to drink there so i begin to
feel like
there's a drink i just want a glass of
champagne
so um i think i related to that
and just
you know her
the voice of this woman in her 60s who's
still trying to stay on top of things
it's a voice you don't often hear from
in films um
and uh and you just go yeah guildy we
put it out there man
and i just think he root for her and it
as i said it's a voice you don't hear
from much yeah you've had this
incredible career like it's pretty
incredible what you've achieved so far
i'm always curious as an actor i'm sure
you get lots of stuff coming your way
sent to you
what does a role have to have at this
point in your career
to make you be interested in it because
i'm sure you're like nope do a lot of
things at this point well i am fortunate
that i get to read a bunch of things
i think it's either i fall in love or i
don't
and in this case
even though the character of hildy
really
drew me the film always has to be about
something more than just the characters
and this film is
um
it's about sort of
you know this woman's struggle just to
stay on top of things
uh
and um so i i guess i do
but
that being said
that sort of um
thing takes me lots of different
directions i'm about to go to australia
to play a farmer
you know and then after that i'm going
to be playing a um
a sort of grand dom and then after that
i'm going to be playing like a
british
double 07 sort of person so i'm jumping
around a lot and i must say i'm having a
great time i love that there's another
project coming out that is like so dear
to my heart it will be in ghostbusters
afterlife which is crazy to me that you
know 37 years later i know you'll be
back in this character like what does
that feel like for you because i'm
assuming at the time when that those
films were made you didn't know the
legacy that they would have
no of course we didn't think of of that
we just wanted to make a wonderful film
and in those days you didn't really make
sequels
i think that for us it's such a
family
legacy that to work with ivan reitman's
son jason who's done an amazing job and
this sort of came out of his
thinking about ghostbusters and what
would make sense now it's full of heart
it's very funny it's very charming and
it will surprise everybody it's just a
glorious film
i'm super excited to see it anytime i
see those films on television i don't
care how many times i've watched them i
watch it and it's always like a saturday
afternoon or sunday afternoon when
you've done so much in your career i'm
always curious and i love asking people
this like when's the last time you sat
down and watched something of yourself
on tv like has anything been on where
you were like oh and are you able to
watch yourself on screen because a lot
of people can't like me i'm like i don't
want to look at myself yeah
i think i'll find out tonight because
i'll get to watch the good house with
actual real people
in the theater and that will be
wonderful because for the comedy you
really need an audience and as much as
i've appreciated having good
entertainment at home during the last 18
months
it's exciting to be in a theater with
fellow human beings
so i think i'll try to watch tonight
i think i'll enjoy it
but
frankly i don't sit around watching
things i've done
i have some of the movies but i think my
daughter
she had to see alien at someone else's
house
when she was 12 or something like that
and i don't keep them lying around i
thought this will scare her you know so
ghostbusters actually i let her see of
course of course well it has been an
honor to talk to you thank you so much
for joining bt canada i can't wait for
everybody to see the good house because
i think honestly after the last year and
a half that we've had a lot of people
are really gonna connect with this film
and you know what i wish we could grab a
glass of red wine together sometime but
maybe next week maybe next time next
time such a pleasure to talk to you
dallas thank you for having me an honor
thank you so much
you